MALE SPEAKER: Everyone, I'd
like to welcome Seth Ladd.
I met this guy years ago
in Miami at the Spring
Experience.
And we've touched bases a few
a times over the years.
SETH LADD: Ships passing
in the night.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
So when he joined Google, I
wanted [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
talking to us about Chrome,
like a year ago.
That didn't quite work out.
But now he's working
with Dart.
SETH LADD: We waited for
the new, new thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
SETH LADD: Anyway, thanks
everyone for
taking their time.
My name is Seth.
I'm a developer advocate
with the Chrome team.
So I help partners of all
different sizes get up and
running and on all
their cool stuff.
And Chrome is this
massive thing.
So we have, obviously, the
Chrome browser, Chrome OS,
Chrome Books, Chrome Frame,
HTML5, Chrome Web Store,
JavaScript.
And what's near and dear
to my heart is Dart.
So that's why I'm happy to be
talking to you guys today.
Before I dive into it, I want to
talk a little bit about my
perspective.
And I was talking to Christian
a little bit.
And thanks again
for having me.
Why this is interesting to me,
and why I think we all need to
pay attention to what
this project is
trying to do and say?
My first language was C. So I
kind of jumped in the deep end
way back in the day.
And later on then,
Java came out.
And Java was really just in
me, because I was more
interested in computer science
because I wanted
to get stuff done.
So I was more of the pragmatic
mind at that time.
So to me, Java was just an
easier way to get something
done, garbage collection, bundle
classes and libraries.
I think that was awesome.
The whole SDK [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But what was really cool at
Java at the time was that,
actually, it was of
and for the web.
I mean, at that time Applets, I
think people were trying to
get working.
Obviously, it didn't
really play out.
But I liked the idea,
that concept.
They had a formal URL class.
You could actually load Java
classes, Java byte code over
the network into your virtual.
Like that, that was mind blowing
at the time, just
seeing a modern object-oriented
programming
language native in
a network world.
It was like light
bulbs going off.
So I really, really
dove into that.
Obviously, Java became relegated
to the server side.
But there's still a lot of
these-- it's still pretty
productive.
Later on then, I wanted to be
even more productive, so I
found Ruby on Rails.
And I know you guys are
a big Rail shop.
And so I really took to that.
But I was able to bring over
a lot of the software
engineering principles and
practices that I grew up
programming C and Java.
A lot of design patterns
came over.
A lot of the expectation around
tooling and refactoring
and all that.
Maybe not refactoring so much.
But certainly tooling, unit
testing, design patterns,
object-orientational,
all this good stuff.
And I felt definitely
more productive.
And then I was extremely
lucky to get this gig
at Google and Chrome.
And I remember, I was really
interviewing for App Engine
and that's the service I got.
They were like, actually,
you're going
to be good for Chrome.
And so I wrote in an email,
and I said, I don't really
know JavaScript that well.
I mean, I can get it to do
stuff, but I'm not a
JavaScript ninja.
And they were like, ah,
don't worry about it.
So lucky enough, I'm still
there, even without being a
JavaScript ninja.
But I did learn through the
job and through these
opportunities just how totally
powerful and awesome the
browser is.
So I was able to make the shift
of, oh, everything has
to be on the server, because
that's where the power is to,
wait a minute.
There is actually, a really
capable browser now, with
these runtime APIs, and fast
execution engines.
And OK, cool.
I can see how these two roles
can complement each other.
But I was never able to fully
dive in with the full set of
expectations that I had,
from my experience
in the other platform.
And again, that's as much
on me as anything else.
But when I heard about this
Dart project, well, light
bulbs again went off.
Because I said, OK, this is a
structured platform, allowing
me to develop software
that I--
or meeting the needs and
expectations of developers
like me, yet delivers software
for the browser, which is the
most ubiquitous platform out
there and getting more
powerful every day.
So, again, light bulbs go off.
I said, this is something I
want to pay attention to.
This is something I want
to help out with.
Now, I'm going to use this
time to talk about the
philosophy and motivation around
Dart and then show you
some of the code.
And just give you an idea where
the project's at and
where it's going.
Is that OK?
Our goal is to help app
developers from all different
platforms write complex, high
performance client apps for
the modern web.
OK, so you can see the word
that's missing up here.
The word Dart, actually,
isn't on here.
And that's on purpose.
The Dart projects is about
insuring the web remains a
compelling and productive
environment for app
developers.
In fact, back when Chrome
launched, we thought, this is
the browser for web apps.
Turns out, we're a little
ahead of the time.
So speed, simplicity, and
security was the message that
resonated with people.
We always had, in the back of
our heads , people should be
writing apps.
It's more than just interactive
sites and engines.
And so if you're able to do
really large scale app
development in JavaScript,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], whatever
you're doing, that's
fantastic.
We think that there's room on
the web, room in the world for
developer choice.
And as long as everyone's going
towards this goal of
complex, multifeature, high
performance apps are running
in the browser, that's what we
want to see, and what we want
to help make happen.
Maybe Dart is a way
to do that.
So technically it's structured
web programming.
It's really an entire, batteries
included, platform.
It's not just a language.
Certainly there's a language.
But there's also tools
that get added here.
There's a virtual machine.
There is, of course,
a libraries.
And probably, most importantly,
it compiles to
JavaScript.
Again, getting back to the
previous slide, where what
we're really just trying to do
is help people deliver awesome
apps for the web.
So it has to work on the
entire modern web.
It's a totally open-source
project, announced, actually,
not too long ago, just in
October of last year.
It's all in Google code.
And I'll probably say this many
times, but do keep in
mind that the entire project is
still technology preview.
So what does that mean?
So when we launched in October
and still today--
well, when we launched in
October, even more, things
were generally compiling.
We had some core libraries.
We had a virtual machine
that added a lot of
features but not all.
So you can see the direction the
project was going in, but
it's very, very early-- still
it is early in the project.
And being launched so we can get
that feedback, so we can
hear from app developers, like
you guys, about what you need.
And so we're not even in
an alpha state yet.
But hopefully you can see
where we're going.
But there's still time to send
that feedback in and help
direct the project.
So we're going to be talking
over a lot of stuff.
I don't know how much time we
have. We'll get through as
much as we can.
Motivation and languages, we'll
look at some of the cool
new features of the language.
We're not going to look
at the whole thing.
We'll look at some code and
look at what's new.
So the current web, people are
obviously developing apps for
the web today.
There's certainly a lot of
neat parts about that.
Small to medium apps are
still easy to develop.
You can see that over
and over again.
How many start-ups, how many
business, how many--
everyone launches a web app.
It's still easy to do
the smaller things.
Platform independence
is obviously a key
feature of the platform.
You can write JavaScript, DHTML
code and get, on every
operating system that you can
think of, and if you look hard
enough on modern smartphones
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
No application installation
is great.
You can click a link
and you're there.
And not only is that technically
is a great feature
of the web, but that clicking
a blue link and delivering a
new app just on the next page
refresh, also has a great
social contract with users.
They know that clicking that
blue link it not going to eat
their computer.
And that's really great.
Supporting incremental
development, the web does that
really well.
There's a couple different
things I mean there.
One is, you start out by trying
a couple functions, add
more functions.
You can start small and grow.
Also, deploying with that,
you can deploy
one just more thought.
You don't have to
think in a large
distribution bundle for that.
The platform's improving
tremendously fast. It's very,
hard even for us to keep up
with all the new HTML5
features and APIs.
And this last point is really
near and dear to my heart.
I helped bring Angry
Birds to web.
And to me Angry Birds
is a litmus
test of modern browsers.
So to run Angry Birds you need
a modern JavaScript engine,
and you need hardware
acceleration for graphics, and
you need features like the
app cache to run offline.
So to me it's, if you can run
Angry Birds on your browser,
then you're running
a modern browser.
When I looked last-- this is
a couple of months old--
30% to 50% of all desktop,
laptop, notebook web users can
play Angry Birds.
It's across all different
browsers.
I don't know how many hundreds,
and hundreds, and
hundreds, and hundreds of
millions of people that is.
That many, that is a really,
really big number.
And to me that says, we're
crossing over that threshold
of not thinking twice about
delivering apps that use these
awesome features, because you're
going to have such a
large user base.
So that's all good.
However we believe that building
large apps is still
very challenging.
It's hard to find the
program's structure.
It's hard to look at a large
JavaScript app today and
understand where the modules,
where the components, where
the libraries, get together.
Where does the program start?
We believe that the lack of
static types is a hindrance.
When you think of the vendors
that give you, in terms of
tooling or just documentation
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Like I was trying to port some
docs from libraries in Dart,
and I had no idea what the
parameters are, its methods.
You just don't know, unless you
manually trace through the
burn instruction.
I think we can do better
than that.
It's taken a very long time to
have decent JavaScript tools.
WebStorm, for instance, is a
pretty good web editor today.
It's less than a year old, I
think, the new version that
does all the stuff.
Though you would expect, it
still doesn't do everything
that we have on other platforms.
And we should ask
ourselves, why do we have
better things than
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And really that, even though
these engines, like V8, are
getting faster and faster at
release, pure start-up time is
actually too slow.
You still have to parse all
of those scripts as
text to start an app.
I mean, that's insane that every
time you start up your
desktop, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Chrome had to parse
your C code.
We can definitely do better.
And then you just think, well
the web has been around for 15
plus years, and there's
a lot of cruft there.
And certainly a strength of the
web is the first original
web page still renders its
[? age ?] process.
That is amazing.
That's not anything I
want to get rid of.
But there are pieces like deep
in the dark alleyways and
corners of the API that we
question does that still need
to be there.
And we don't really have a
way to deprecate our web.
Like, what would happen if
somebody took a fresh look?
So that brings us to
the Dart platform.
So we got a look at
the good parts.
We looked at the parts
we don't approve.
And at least, from the team's
perspective, we can look at
the experience we have, both
inside Google and the
different teams inside Google.
Building things like closure
compiler, which doesn't really
have a vocal developer
adoption.
But I talk to a lot of people,
and they love this tool.
[? We ?]
[? at ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] toolkit, which
again enables these
larger structured web apps.
Google itself develops larger
apps like Google Docs, Gmail,
Google Plus itself is a really
complex almost entirely script
driven app.
And certainly the team
building, [? I ?]
[? think, ?]
the low-level components
like V8.
So if you take all of that
experience, and then what if
you could package it all up and
make it available to the
entire modern web, and make it
feel like it's for everybody?
That's what we're trying to do
with the current platform.
And by the way, since it's
awesome that it's a small
crowd, so feel free to
stop me at any time.
It's way more interesting
to do it two-way.
I hope we get to the point where
I've learned from you
about what your experiences are
developing web apps, and
your take on this stuff,
so don't hesitate.
And then we'll talk about this
a little bit though.
We firmly believe that
innovation is essential.
I think I saw some quote.
I think it was related
to Dart.
That no one has a monopoly
on innovation for web.
And they feel very strongly
about that.
I mean, when you look at
the formal side, oh,
it's open web platform.
And to me, open means, everyone
has an open, free
shot at grassroots groundswell
support,
improving on these ideas.
And the community should
embrace that.
The community should
embrace people
trying different things.
And not everything
is going to work.
But we don't want anyone
to say, you can't try.
And we already talked about
it a little bit.
And the aim of this process is
in maintaining the web as
relevant, interesting,
productive, pleasurable for
app developers, for all of us.
Cool.
So if you have questions
about that, you can
stop me at any time.
Let's dive into the language.
This is code-heavy talk.
That would be boring.
But I do want to call out a
couple of different features
that might be interesting
to you guys.
So just the eye-level review
of Dart language.
It's a simple, unsurprising,
object-oriented programming
language with interfaces
and signal inheritance.
At that point, you
can just yawn.
And go to sleep, and check
your emails stuff.
But that's pretty much
exactly the response
that we want to get.
We believe that the language
itself should be very familiar
to developers in a
wide spectrum.
And the Dart project is not the
time and place for us to
invent like the next Pascal.
And even though that might be
totally awesome to programming
language as a discipline, we'd
end up with six users.
And the Dart platform or project
is trying to appeal to
an army of web developers, an
army of Java, an army of C
Sharp developers.
So innovating on things like
language syntax is not going
to help people easily get
up on this platform.
So we take a very familiar
approach to this language.
But that doesn't meant that we
don't take this opportunity to
introduce a couple
of new things or
clean up a couple things.
So we'll look at some
of that stuff.
To me, the coolest thing that
the Dart project is trying to
do is introduce optional
static typing.
Now, it's not the first language
to do this, but
arguably, it's the first
language which is targeted to
mass adoption to try an optional
static typing.
The best way to think about
optional static typing is
they're simply annotations.
They're simply documentation.
It's a way for you to
communicate your intent to
your other developers and
your fellow machines.
So I don't know the background
in this room.
But if you come from structured
languages, you're
like, well, obviously,
I want static types.
They tell my tools a lot.
They tell my fellow
developers a lot.
Yes, these are great things.
But, again, there's an army of
web developers out there
writing JavaScript that have
never seen a type.
May never want to see a type.
And this platform should
appeal to them.
So again, you look at the
spectrum of JavaScript guys,
who may want to validate a form,
all the way out to the
people who want to build
abstract factory class
factories, and everything
in between.
Optional static types is our
effort to allow you to
gradually get familiar with
the language and then
gradually add types,
as you see fit.
And then just more and more
benefits start to appear.
Philosophically, we don't want
to introduce any strong handed
type theorem checker that
beats you over the head.
Especially, when
you think of--
incremental development is
really important, especially
to the web.
So you should be able to
write code that doesn't
exactly work perfectly.
Because you may not actually
run that code yet.
And so you should be able to
write a little code and
refresh, write a little
code and refresh.
That's the cycle
we want to get.
You can't have that in more
structured languages that have
mandatory static types.
But there are a lot of benefits
to static types.
So optional static types is our
effort to maybe make both
of these standards work well.
And so before I dive more into
those, I'll explain how
optional static types
might be applied.
And it's important to understand
that the two
runtime modes for Dart.
So the default mode of Dart
programs, the mode that when
you start the Dart program, the
user hits the URL and it
goes, is what we call
production mode.
Production mode is the fast
way, the default way
of trying to code.
It's more or less ignoring
static type annotations.
In fact, the static type
annotations have no runtime,
so they don't affect the
runtime semantics.
So it's great for
when you deploy.
But when you develop or write
unit tests, or are just
building out your program, you
want to run what's then called
the checked mode.
Checked mode, you start
to see the benefits of
these static types.
Because dynamic type
assertions turn on.
And, for instance, if you try
to assign an integer to a
string or something, the dynamic
type assertion will
kick-in, throw that exception,
say, he you're doing something
I don't think you really
meant to do.
I'm going to stop you,
and let you fix that.
And again, this is a developer
client choice.
You can say, I'm going to run
checked mode I'm going to get
all these benefits.
Assert statements
are turned on.
We believe it's really, really
good for development.
Now that we understand the two
different runtime modes, let's
look back at optional
static types.
So during development time, the
optional static types give
you, for instance, the
ability to run an
intelligent static analysis.
Again, somebody coming from Java
or C Sharp is like, of
course I have this stuff.
So we have this too in Dart.
If you're typing along, and
it notices something is
incorrect, it's going to give
you a little squiggly and say,
that's not exactly
what you thought.
It is tuned to be unobtrusive.
So we do prefer warnings
and not errors.
And again, because you should be
able to write code and hit
refresh and run.
Again, we're not trying to
make you jump through a
tremendous amount of hoops just
to write your program.
And then, again, in that time
all of your site type enable
these dynamic type
checks, boom.
So back over in runtime.
This is a little misleading,
so I'm going
to have to fix this.
Sorry.
So this is development time.
This is when you are
writing the code.
The warnings can get
all turned on, and
it can static analyze.
This is at runtime.
So you're still in
checked mode.
But while your program's
running, that's when all the
type assertions are on.
You hit that code.
It can throw the exception
for you.
So you can do warnings
while you code.
Exceptions catched during
checked mode as you execute.
And so, for instance,
you might write
something like T x=o.
Then in checked mode, this is
going to be automatically
inserted in your code.
And so this is really cool.
So if you try to assign
something that's on T, it's
going to warn you.
That's cool.
So let's see an example
of this stuff working.
And I [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So now I'm in the Dart editor.
And I'm going to create--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
servers.
And we'll dive into this a
little bit more later.
So here's a simple Dart program
where we can just
illustrate these kind of bugs.
So let's say to your buddy down
the hall, I'm going to
write you a method.
This is going to be awesome.
And it's going to do this.
And you're like, yes.
I totally need to add stuff.
And thankfully did that.
So, so let's try to run this.
Probably your didn't see it.
But here's three.
Just as you would expect if you
looked at this code today.
So that's cool.
But then later one,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Well, actually, really what I
meant is this, because that's
what I needed in my code.
So he comes and adds the type
annotations in the program.
Thus being a lot more clear
about what that does.
Cool.
And then I don't know if we can
see it, but now the static
analysis can kick on and say,
well, obviously, if one is an
integer, and you told
me that, if you're
going to take a string.
So hey, n is not assignable
to string.
Heads up.
This may not be what you want.
But it's a warning
not an error.
So if we run this program,
it still runs.
Because I'm running in
production mode here.
And remember that your type
annotations don't affect the
runtime semantics.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two strings together, but
everything is fine.
However, let's go on,
and and take this.
We're going to run
a checked mode.
Now, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I want to know these things.
So now the checked mode is
coming on, it's going to
actually stop the program and
throw an exception, that you
can catch, or do whatever,
or just be warned.
And it just has some type
of string or X.
So now my program is helping
me as a developer.
Adding two simple words, string
and string, now you get
all these benefits.
And again, if you come from
other platforms, you're like,
yes, of course, we love it.
But we're trying to create a
type system that doesn't get
in your way, but helps you.
That's why the warning's
there.
So that's what's going on.
Cool.
So let's look at some other new
features of the platform.
One is isolates.
We'll look at some samples
of those in a little bit.
I don't know if you guys are
familiar with Erlang, but
Erlang was quite successful with
this idea of actor-based
concurrency.
We should be able start these
isolated actors in the system,
totally memory isolated.
And you pass messages
back and forth.
It's, many believe, a much safer
way to write parallel
code, concurrent code.
Because nothing is
actually shared.
And so Dart takes a lot of the
inspiration from this.
And so we built a system
called isolates.
Isolates are memory isolated
chunks of running code.
And communicate between
them via messages.
These messages are copied
back and forth.
So you get all the benefits of
no shared state concurrent
programming, a simple
library that's just
built into the platform.
There's also a pragmatic reason
why we have this is
because Dart is single
threaded.
And if you know, JavaScript
is also single threaded.
So one of the core tenets of
Dart is that everything has to
compile to JavaScript in
some fairly sane way.
So we couldn't build
threads into Dart.
Because how would
you get that?
Do you want to map those
to the web brokers?
The web brokers don't have
shared state like
[? correcting. ?]
So anyway, we developed out
isolates and it's pretty cool.
So lightweight units
of execution.
So what are they good for?
Well, certainly concurrency.
Everyone has multicore machines,
even your phones are
getting multicores, so we have
to have an answer to
concurrency.
If you think about modern web
page today, it's just full of
injected JavaScript, like your
Plus one button, and your
Facebook like, and your Twitter
button, and ads, and
analytics, and you name it.
And so it's all jammed
in there on the page.
And if you don't write the code
perfectly, and if that
[? had ?] third party libraries,
we got iframes, and
all this other stuff, you're
basically going to all operate
on same key.
I mean, like that's.
So wouldn't it be interesting if
each one of those could be
an isolate?
And you'd then just have a lot
more confidence in your apps,
like they can trample on each
other, and have to have an
easier way to do it other
than iframes.
Another interesting usage of
isolates is, what if you can
mask client-server
communication, just like you
use isolates to communicate,
or ports to communicate
between isolates in
running Dart app.
Wouldn't it be interesting to
just extrapolate that and have
an isolate between the
client and server.
And you just post messages.
And it just takes care
of it for you.
So we see a couple uses
for isolates.
First and foremost, Dart is a
web programming language.
And, again, this our chance to
look back at the platform and
the API and say, what would we
do differently if you did it
again today.
And then jQuery really
pioneered this.
Anybody that's a JavaScript
developer pretty much is a
jQuery developer.
Everyone injects the same 30
k of JavaScript into every
single app everyone writes.
There's a very good
reason for that.
They made the DOM feel
natural to the
Java programming language.
They made the DOM feel
like JavaScript.
It was awesome.
So, of course, Dart is going to
take inspiration from that.
And we're building out what we
call the HTML library to make
interacting with the DOM feel
very natural to Dart.
So collections of nodes or
children should just be Dart
collections.
And the method name should look
like what you might call
them if you were programming
Dart.
And we also need this
opportunity to clean up or
remove some of the dark corners
and alleyways you
probably think you shouldn't
be touching.
And we'll get into all that.
This is a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on the next slide.
So let's look at how you
might execute Dart.
So you always start out
seeing a Dart source.
Now, you may not see the Dart
source directly in the Dart
virtual machine.
Because this is part of
the Dart platform.
The Dart virtual machine runs
just fine on the server or on
the command line.
Much like JavaScript runs fine
on the command line which
powers Node.js.
You have to give the
Dart execute while
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This can be embedded
also in a browser.
We have a beta virtual app.
Or you can [? try ?] some and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] tools.
So some of your tools may be
compiling into JavaScript,
which is totally critical to the
adoption of Dart and just
being a citizen on the web.
Or you might mine for a tool
that can generate snapshots.
That's what I want
to talk about.
So snapshots [? are ?]
[? another idea. ?]
And it's our answer
to running--
to fix the slow start up
performance problem we see in
the current web applications
today.
So wouldn't it be amazing if you
could start your app from
cache, say on your mobile
device, from a snapshot, a
serialization of the [? key ?]
from the last time you ran
your [? program. ?]
We've seen, when we did this,
when we tested, we saw an
order of magnitude improvement
of load time.
And this stuff,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It ain't that apps start fast,
because V8 seems fast.
But again, when you know that
you get an order magnitude
better, and you show the time
signing in Microsoft, Amazon,
Google, every time you increase
the speed or decrease
latency, your revenues go up.
The usage goes up.
There's a direct correlation
between speed and bottom line,
the dollars.
So this stuff is important.
Snapshot is a feature of
the virtual machine.
But pretty cool, so
good on that one.
So this some of the features
about the language.
We'll look at it a little
bit more later.
But I want to now shift to the
other elements of the platform
like the tools.
We saw the editor
real briefly.
We believe that tooling is as
important as just shipping
language back to our
virtual machine.
So we built an editor
based on RCP.
We basically just took the
widgeting components and built
an editor only for editing
Dart a fun, pleasurable
experience.
So things like syntax
highlighting, which we saw,
code completion, warnings and
errors, that we saw there too.
You can fire-off the Dart
virtual machine.
You can fire-off Dartium, which
is the Dart VM built
inside Chrome.
They can debug between
the two.
It's the things you might
expect in an editor.
It's not trying to be like
an IDEs that implies this
massive, monolithic thing.
And web developers, they
want very fast ,
going past this stuff.
So you see a lot people use the
blindtext and TextMates.
We're trying to build something
that gives you the
features that play off the
language benefits, yet still
remains a lightweight, like
a text editor would.
And so that's our goal there.
There's always the SDK, if you
just love loading on the
command line.
And this is all downloadable
stuff today.
The SDK has the Dart2js, the
serial compiler to JavaScript.
There's the Dart virtual
machine built in.
It has all the core libraries.
We just put the unit
test in there.
I believe we can put the
dartdoc util in there.
That's where [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
eventually is going to live.
And just like all the stuff, you
can download this and play
with it today.
And then there's a Chromium with
the Dart virtual machine.
This ships in the editor
download today.
And it's just like
what it sounds.
We took the Dart VM,
put it in Chromium,
wired up all the bindings.
So just like you might
communicate with HTML5 APIs
with JavaScript, you can
communicate with
those APIs with Dart.
The dev tools also work.
And we'll see this
in a second.
So it'll be a while before this
is actually deployed out
into the wild.
So what's really awesome about
this is the editor, the editor
debug development cycle.
I don't know.
Has anyone played with GWT,
Google Web Toolkit?
So you write your Java code,
then just compile stuff, then
you reload.
And there's a dev mode, which
made it a little bit better.
And just recently they
had a super dev mode.
But there is this cycle, where
we have to compile.
Well, what's awesome about
JavaScript web programming
today, write a code, reload.
Well, reload is the
web's compiler.
We want that experience
for Dart developers.
So you can write code in the
editor, and run it in Dartium
or run, develop, run, develop,
run, develop.
And then when you're ready to
deploy, then you compile to
JavaScript and ship out.
So this would be awesome
development an
debug tool for a while.
Christian?
MALE SPEAKER: How do you see--
what's the future of Dart in
non-Chromium browsers?
SETH LADD: I think that the Dart
team has work to do to
finish up the platform.
We're still seeing things
like reflection.
Increase the speed.
Increase development
productivity.
We're still in technology
preview.
So I think, rightfully so,
people are going to wait and
see approach.
And that's fair.
That's the pragmatic thing.
They're waiting to see how
Dart can deliver on these
hypotheses, if you will, for
DOM and web development.
So we'll see what happens.
But it's still early, so we've
got work to do to prove out
these theories.
AUDIENCE: Is the speed
improvement based on comparing
to all services starting in
Chromium or is it based on the
code produced from
Dart versus?
SETH LADD: Both.
We track the performance of
both and Dart compiled to
JavaScript and native Dart.
AUDIENCE: I know.
It tested in another browser?
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: The cycles
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
SETH LADD: Our buildbot
is public.
And you can go to the buildbot
and you see all these things
running on all the different
browsers.
And there's definitely work to
do with performance, for sure.
But we are tracking--
AUDIENCE: Are you seeing a
performance improvement on
other browsers, if
you start from--
I guess that's hard to
[? remember ?] and all.
If you start from the
Dart language and it
optimizes in some way--
SETH LADD: So this is something
that GWT does.
GWT can take your Java code,
compile it, and authorize it
for different browsers,
understanding
their particular quirks.
Dart's not yet doing that,
because Dart--
one of GWT's things was like,
back when they started, we're
going to make this work IE6.
There was a vast discrepancy
there.
Dart's targeting modern
browsers.
So that means IE9 and
up, basically.
AUDIENCE: So you're going
to see the speed on
[? programming ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] only
on Chromium, really?
SETH LADD: I wouldn't
go that far.
In fact, again, in many cases
we don't actually see speed
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] yet, because
it's very early in the game.
So what I suspect is that if
you write fairly sane Dart
code, we have a lot of smarts
that generate optimized
JavaScript.
It remains to be seen how much
we'll tweak that JavaScript
for each browser.
But because we're targeting
modern browsers, who have
fairly decent JavaScript
engines, the need for us to
micro-tweak at like,
on day one for
Dart, is greatly minimized.
AUDIENCE: I also had a couple
clarifying questions.
So it sounds like there's
two paths to see
benefit through Dart.
So I can run-- just to clarify--
so one way I could--
SETH LADD: Do you want
me to go back to
this guy, right here?
Is this it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So in the Dart source editor,
I could run pure
JavaScript if I wanted?
SETH LADD: In the Dart source--
in the Dart editor, I
showed you earlier?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I could run through
JavaScript.
SETH LADD: Well, you can
definitely write pure
JavaScript, like you
can write HTML CSS.
The editor will treat
those as text files.
But every modern web app has a
collection of different text
file formats.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm
misunderstanding.
If type in JavaScript, purely,
into the Dart engine--
SETH LADD: Into this
guy, right here?
AUDIENCE: Will it run?
Or does it--
SETH LADD: So no.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
That's not valid syntax.
AUDIENCE: I know, I--
SETH LADD: So let me explain
some of that.
This is an editor.
It mainly understands Dart code,
which is why it's that
stuff showing up.
I can totally do--
AUDIENCE: I guess I was
just wondering if it
makes the code at all?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
Again, so it's now
you edited it.
You're good.
Now, I want to run it.
So there's two different ways
you can run the code.
One's the way I showed you.
Well, three, maybe.
One is the way I showed you.
We'll run it straight in
the virtual machine.
Which we saw down here.
This is just what's being
spit out from VM.
Let's go ahead an jump
to this guy.
This will, hopefully,
make sense to you.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to tell
me that it'll compile to
JavaScript?
SETH LADD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because I
already got that.
What I was wondering, I guess, I
thought that maybe you could
start from JavaScript and slowly
add implementation.
It tells me it can't.
Like if you have some JavaScript
already and you
want to convert it to Dart and
then experiment with that?
SETH LADD: Got it.
Good question.
That's really clever.
So the question was, can you
use the editor or not?
Can you start with JavaScript
and slowly convert it to Dart?
Got to have these two
worlds intermix--
AUDIENCE: And your
answer is, no.
You have to start with Dart.
SETH LADD: So the answer is Dart
does not have a JSNI or
something like GWT has, like
JavaScript Native Interface.
Dart can't directly
synchronicitly interact with
JavaScript.
And the reason for that is,
when you have two virtual
machines, it gets a little
complicated on like who owns
the object, and garbage
collection, and an efficient
RBC mechanism between the two.
And so the way that you interact
or interoperate with
JavaScript, in Dart today,
is via post message.
Just like you might interact
between two iframes, or two
tabs, or two disparate third
party programs. Post message
is how you do that.
So what we see people
do is, they might
have JavaScript code.
They write a layer that turns
that JavaScript code into a
course-grained asynchronous
interface.
That's in Dart.
And then the implementation of
that interface just uses post
message to link you back
to the main page.
So it's definitely not a totally
awesome experience.
But it does work.
AUDIENCE: When I start from Dart
specifically, do I have
like two options on creating the
JavaScript and create it
pretty, so that like people
working in just pure
JavaScript and not
Dart are happy?
Or does it just convert into
Dart optimized JavaScript?
SETH LADD: So the pretty and the
Dart optimized are, right
now, the same thing.
We generate just one version
of the JavaScript.
In fact, I think we'll
see that really soon.
I'll actually show you.
To tie it back to this
experience here, the editor
can both launch this thing
directly in Dartium, or it can
compile to JavaScript for you
and launch it another browser.
AUDIENCE: So how awful is
debugging, generally?
SETH LADD: Yeah,
fair question.
The JavaScript that we generate
today is fairly readable.
And I'll show you
really quickly.
AUDIENCE: But how easily
can I add it back
to the Dart I wrote?
SETH LADD: So we don't yet
have source maps, today.
That would be really awesome.
And I know that's been brought
up a couple times.
AUDIENCE: Even my hand, I find
CoffeeScript hard enough to
realize I did something wrong.
So it's not a tool problem.
It's that I wrote
invalid code.
But it compiled and executed
JavaScript that
didn't do what I wanted.
And I find a lot of JavaScript
that generated behavior that
wasn't intended.
But then locating which process
or compiled statement
generated that, is
that feasible?
SETH LADD: It's so feasible
that we don't
even have source maps.
For those of you who don't know,
a source map's the lines
that you map between the
compile output and the
original source.
And so when you're actually in
the dev tools, as you step
through the program, it'll
actually [? set ?] you through
the source, the original source,
even though it's
executing the generated
JavaScript code.
But we're going to get
there really quick.
I'll show you what a generated
JavaScript code looks like.
It basically looks like
a human wrote it.
Yeah, let's look at that then.
And I'll show you.
That's a good question.
Look at that.
It's actually the next slide.
Very cool.
So completing the tools that we
offer, there's the Dart to
JavaScript compiler, as well.
Which is how you deploy
your app today,
for all modern browsers.
It used to be called Frog,
affectionately.
But now it's simplified
to Dart2js.
Because everyone's like,
what's Frog?
So does use some smarts
out of the gate today.
It does do what we call,
tree shaking.
So it, actually, it compiles in
your whole program and then
shakes the tree.
And then all the unused
or dead code fall off.
And we only ship what's
actually being used.
Which is really cool.
Because that means you can
import all these libraries.
But if you use just 10% of
library you import, then what
gets generated out
is just that 10%.
So that's pretty cool.
And there's more work to do
there to make it even smaller.
And once you understand the
semantics of the code, your
minification can get
a lot smarter.
And so we'll add minification
to the tool chain as well.
So, to answer your questions.
Here's an example.
This is slightly old, but
you get the idea.
Here's some Dart code.
This is pretty self-explanatory.
You have a class here.
This is static method.
And here's your main method,
that calls the static method.
So this is what you would
write in a program.
Then you run it through
the Dart2js compiler.
In this version of Frog, this
is the code that generates.
So it actually fits
on the screen.
And you have main method here.
That's fine.
That makes sense.
In fact, this looks like the
same name and method.
That's good.
Then you look back up here.
So there's a class.
So that's that guy, here.
It says static on it.
That, actually, to me, is
fairly understandable.
This is just one example.
Obviously you could write really
complex Dart code.
The Dart compile should be smart
enough to optimize that.
But we're not, out of the
gate, trying to make,
purposely, confusing or
crazy JavaScript.
The development and debug
experience for JavaScript
should be fairly sane
and logical to us.
And that's where we are today.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So it's important to remember
though, we're still in the
technology [? preview ?], so
Dart is by no means done.
There's still key features,
like reflection, that are
currently still in being
implemented.
In fact, we just changed the
semantics for equality.
So changes are still
happening.
We don't yet have an Enum.
That's probably pretty useful.
Patter action is really useful
if you have isolate
communication and messages.
We know we want to have that.
And of course, there's no
question about how we should
drive Chrome.
So it's still early on.
And this is why we like to get
the feedback to know what's
important to you guys.
Now, I hear the debugging of
JavaScript is really important.
So maybe that's the
something to hear.
So this is really cool.
Just like [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
one of the things that's
really important to any kind of
ecosystem is a way to get
developers to feel empowered
to share, publish, use,
install, discover libraries.
Java has Maven.
Node.js has MPM.
Ruby has Gems and Butler.
So Dart is building what we
affectionately call Pub.
You play darts in a pub.
And that's our package
manager.
And it'll do things like enable
installation discovery,
bundling, all that good stuff.
And to me, this is one of those
key missing pieces, and
one that should be at launch.
You'll now see this kind
of ecosystem bloom.
Because we have all these
libraries out there, right
now, but there's no economical
way to pull them
all in right now.
So anyway, we're keenly worried
about developer
experience.
And this is the kind of thins
that we feel are part of the
values we put into
our package.
Now, the proposal is
live right now.
And you can shoot comment
to this and respond.
That's the kind of stuff
we like to hear.
How much time do we have?
MALE SPEAKER: 15
minutes or so.
SETH LADD: Cool.
Well, I won't go into
these then.
But this just gives you the idea
that people are building
things for Dart today,
crypto libraries,
NEC Frameworks, logging.
All the kind of infrastructure
things you'd think would
happen in early days.
So in other words, people
are building stuff.
And it's neat to watch them.
And build upon what other people
have built already, so
early on in the project.
The online, that community
is also growing.
We have a Plus pages,
hashtags, Twitter.
Dartosphere is what
we call a planet.
So like all the blog aggregation
is there.
Dartbug.com is a short URL
over to the bug tracker.
We love that.
A blog here for news.
So it's happening online
as well, like that.
Useful resources, you might
find useful, just
to makey you aware.
We've a language tour.
Where you can just walk yourself
through, at a high
level, all these features.
We have API docs, which
have comments as well.
So you can browse around,
again, [? one ?] for the
[? platform ?]
libraries, things
like futures.
I think that's really useful for
asynchronous programming,
timers, clocks, date
manipulation.
This is one of the things
I love about Java.
It shipped with a pretty
comprehensive core library.
And if you need it, the web
platform had this too.
That's less coding to
ship around there.
So you can browse around that.
And then this one's
really cool.
You can't see the whole thing.
But this translates JavaScript
idioms to Dart.
And so this can help you if
your JavaScript guy or
programmer.
And you want to know like, I'm
always iterating through
arrays in Java.
How am I going to
do that in Dart?
Does that make sense?
You can use this.
This a huge page.
This itself is written with
Dart, and, oddly enough, XSLT.
Found a good use for it.
Anyway, that's pretty
useful for that.
And then shameless plug.
This is a freebie book, kind
of high level stuff.
You can get that at O'Reilly's
for free.
So yeah, I mean, the
main thing is that
Dart is getting ready.
It's not quite done.
But we envision it as a whole
batteries included platform,
language, libraries, editors,
virtual machines, browser
integrations.
We view it as for structured
web programming.
So we have a set of
use cases in mind.
We're working with some
assumptions around that.
And we love feedback, as many
ways as you can do it, mailing
list, bugs, the Plus feed,
whatever, my email.
It's all good.
So with a few minutes left, I'll
show you a couple more
code samples, and then whatever
questions you guys got.
AUDIENCE: Are there any internal
teams that have
signed up to start developing
with this?
SETH LADD: I don't know if
we're talking about this.
That's no comment.
Yeah, but that's a
good question.
So let's start here.
We saw this, [? probably ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This is just the obligatory
hello world.
What I like about this, though,
is it's very obvious.
It's very familiar.
And there's nothing really
surprising here.
But it doesn't have all this
ceremonious garbage that Java
would have.
So again, we can be structured
and familiar without making
you type out public, static,
[? void, ?] main, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla.
You still get a processing
point.
I know where my program
starts.
And that's actually something
you don't know about
JavaScript.
That's kind of cool.
Let's look at class.
This is a little
bit artificial.
But it shows a couple of things
I like about this.
I hope you guys can see this.
[? Each cloud ?] again,
syntax is really
familiar, class points.
We can see the optional
typing here.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] works
just fine.
What I love is this, the
syntactic sugar for
constructors.
You always type this dot x
equals x, this dot y equals y.
Why not just say, this
dot x, this dot y.
Cool.
Works for me.
You can see the static method
being called upon that, here.
One of the things that
we loved, or we're
beginning to see this--
let me do this--
is using the static type of
annotations to surface the
area of your code.
Again, to provide documentation
to your fellow
humans and machines.
Really, what we want to
encourage is using types to
cite type annotations
here, and here.
This parcel will flow
down to this.
So that when you give the code
to a fellow programmer, he can
immediately see what the
expectations are.
That alone is a huge
improvement over
what we have today.
And then, for instance,
when you start doing
that kind of stuff--
let's just mark this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it obviously doesn't know
how to complete this.
But I do.
So I tell the system it's point,
then the system gets a
lot more smart.
And obviously, things begin to
[? expect ?] from any modern
programming environment,
kick in, boom.
A lot more productive.
So highlight that
kind of stuff.
There's been talk about, while
it could be non-enbabled,
local-type inference, and that
would be cool, and I think
that will come at some point.
That would make sense.
Some of you had questions
about that.
And then let's look at--
we saw this guy before.
So this is an example of what
we call, HTML library.
A totally artificial example
here, but it shows you that
this is a little bit more
jQuery-esque, if you will.
You create a new elements with
this nice-- this is called a
name constructor.
Which I love named constructors,
because before
you had just overloaded
instructions, different
combination of arguments.
You never knew what they were
for or what they did.
So now you have a constructor,
for instance, like from Jason.
Good.
Makes sense.
And then, you can just interact
with the attributes
of an element just as you might
properties of the class,
so ID, text.
Classes here, is just
a Dart collection.
So just like you can add things
in our collection, you
can add class.
That just works.
And this is how you had
an anonymous event
callback, if you will.
See the click handler?
Reads pretty easy to
me on click app.
And then, again, elements
is a Dart collection.
So you just added your new
element to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So let's run this.
Adjust the mouse.
Come on computer.
Double [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That's so funny.
[INAUDIBLE]
So we are now running this
inside what we call Dartium,
which is the Dart
virtual machine.
Sorry, embedded inside
Chromium.
Here we are.
Just to prove that
it all works.
Great.
So this answers sort of your
debugging question.
This isn't exactly
what you asked.
But it shows you the direction
that the team is going in.
I can fire up the dev tools
and get in the way here.
The dev tools are awesome
for JavaScript.
And we're making those
work in Dart as well.
So, for instance, you can insert
a breakpoint here.
And notice this would
be Dart code.
Let me go back up here.
And sure enough, it would
stop right here.
You can inspect objects.
It's really cool, just like you
would expect in dev tools
for JavaScript.
We'll just keep going.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The debug experience here
should be great.
And what they're working on
now is actually wiring the
debugger of the editor,
communicating directly with
the virtual machine here.
So you should use the editor
to step through and inspect
variables and all that stuff,
living in a nice, development
experience.
And writing and enabling
the [? Dart code. ?]
Finally, I'll show isolates.
That's the cool stuff I like.
You remember isolates?
Those are a kind of hypervisor
running the code in different
memory isolated segments,
and possibly
different threads or processes.
So, they basically
clean up the API.
It looks pretty good to me.
Spawn function to create an
isolate, give it a function as
the entry point.
Just happens that
it's up here.
In our simple one, up here,
every isolate has a port.
So I say, OK, well, we'll
send out a message.
And when I get that message,
reply and just, basically,
echo the message.
And then down here, I'm
going to send a
message via send port.
I'm going to say, hi.
And then when I get
the response--
and this is using futures--
go ahead and print.
Then takes the function, and
print is a function.
Just so that makes sense.
So let's run this.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SETH LADD: They're built in.
So you can't see it down here.
[? It's already ?]
Been [? hightlighted ?]
Hi, THC echo.
So we sent a message.
I responded.
Sent it back.
I got it here, and I sent that,
the object I got, as a
response to the print
function, and the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So isolates are really
cool, and a lot
of cool things happen.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
implicit argument here?
SETH LADD: It's not an
implicit argument?
Oh, it is being passed
into this.
I could have done this.
Let's see here.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: So there's on thing
I haven't seen here, some
examples yet, any kind of code
that you're blocking.
SETH LADD: So yes, we just
had enclosure right here.
AUDIENCE: Is that
what that is?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
In fact, Dart has
sane closures.
And if we had any more time
I [? tell you. ?]
Maybe afterwards,
I'll show you.
But this, in Dart, is totally
logical [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And I'll show you some
samples of these.
So cool.
So that's what I have, given
the time allotted.
So I totally think you guys are
spending lunch with me and
the questions.
And I'll just hang out for as
long as you guys want, and we
can chat about all the stuff
I'd like to know.
Actually, I'm most visibly
interested in how much modern
client-side web development
you guys do.
What are your clients
asking for?
We envision Dart being
applicable and relevant in a
world where the application
lives in the browser.
And the server is a restful,
adjacent endpoint.
And then you start writing
you app offline first.
You start writing your app
with Dart or JavaScript.
And just like might in iOS or
Android app [? in devo ?], you
don't ask the server
to generate your
Android views for you.
So we want to build tools to
that help developers build
apps that are modern
client-side apps.
And I'm totally curious if
that's what you guys are
trying to do, want to do,
are being asked to do?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess then,
responding to that.
One thing I don't think I've
heard you mention is what is
the view generation in Dart?
SETH LADD: Very astute.
The reason I did not talk about
that is because that is
still being worked on.
That's like even more technology
preview than what
we have. And I'm personally,
really excited for that.
I can tell a little bit about
the philosophy, in 30 seconds,
like what we think.
If that would be helpful.
We do believe that we'll
ship a UI app stack
library with Dart.
It'll be another library you
get along with them.
And it's going to operate on
the assumptions of offline
first.
It's going to operate on the
assumption that the view
creation happens in a client.
It's going to operate on the
assumption of data mining,
observables, events.
It's going to very much give you
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] modern
client-side app stack.
But it will give you those
pieces like observables, and
views, themes, and those
sort of things.
AUDIENCE: Are we talking about a
DOM element generation in an
accessible form, or is this Dart
takes over all of your
new styling, your CSS is lost?
SETH LADD: So nothing
takes over anything.
The question was, for the video,
are we talking about
accessible DOM creation
and manipulation?
Or are we talking about Dart
taking over the whole thing?
Is that fair?
AUDIENCE: Right, or at least the
components it generates.
Do you have any hope of styling
them or interacting
with them to then fix their
own JavaScript?
SETH LADD: Yeah, for
the recording.
It was, do we have any hope to
interact with those external
JavaScripts?
So nothing we're going to
provide is going to force you
into anything.
That's for sure.
It's definitely going to have an
opinion, but I don't think
it's even possible for us to
be like, you can never ever
touch this again.
You can always just walk the DOM
through your JavaScript.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Just like, yeah.
It may not be a good idea.
SETH LADD: Right.
So one of the things that we've
been playing with is a
template system.
That you write a snippet of
HTML, and it has Mustache like
things in it.
But that, you actually compile
that to Dart code.
And it takes all your HTML
elements and actually generate
the code, like you saw before.
It'll create the elements
for you.
So it actually parses
the HTML.
That's statically generated
for you.
So then you can use
those as snippets.
And you can actually get
handles to each of the
elements via IDs.
So the template system
will do this for you.
In other words, we're moving
in a direction away from
string manipulation on the
client, to nodes and element
manipulation.
So that's kind of philosophy
number one.
Philosophy number 2 is, this is
something the web component
spec is doing for us.
Which is it's going to
utilize what area
called scope style sheets.
Scope style sheets are
really awesome.
You can say, I'm going to buy
these styles, for just this
node and all its
children nodes.
This then allows you to actually
create components,
which is something the
web actually lacks.
It's just crazy when
you think about it.
So Dart is going is to play off
of this theme, as well.
And so when you create these
templates, you're going to be
able to also specify the CSS
that goes with that block.
And we will go through, parse
the CSS, monitor all the class
names, and the names
are reimported.
So you can ship this template
as an actual widget or
component and have confidence
that it doesn't mess with
anything else.
So if you were relying on a
particular class name in
outside, in this particular
library, it
might be a little difficult.
But we don't think that using
JavaScript to manipulate class
names is the way to do it.
We think you should actually
write Dart code and manipulate
via calls in your app stack, and
have that manifest itself
out, underlying through the
themes and the skins layers to
manipulate CSS.
So in other words, we can code
as grants or [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
direct manipulation of
the attributes at
the application layer.
AUDIENCE: Sure, but I think what
I'm hearing is, it would
be hard for them to have global
style sheets that apply
to DOM elements with
known classes
generated through Dart.
SETH LADD: So what I'm
talking about is
just a template engine.
There's other work going on.
And this is why we had
to shift head.
And so we then don't improve
these theories out, that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] with the
constant themes and styles.
Again, we're not exactly
sure what format
it's going to take.
But that might help manage
the styles for you.
Of course, you can always insert
a style tag up at the
top, and doing the cascade
stuff might happen.
But we're experimenting with
the a route where you would
treat us like a a modern on
other platforms. So do it
through the libraries and APIs
that have interfaces or
abstraction provided by the
platform, not direct
manipulation of attributes
in CSS files.
But this stuff is even
more preview.
So this is just what
we're thinking of.
And we're trying to prove it on
out and see what happens.
We should follow
up all clients.
I think, you're trying to go
some-- like, I want to
accomplish x.
I'm not fully understanding.
So I'm not answering your
question great.
But I want to learn a little
more about what that thing is
that you want enabled to do.
AUDIENCE: What about testing
support [? factory, ?]
into terms of the tools and
in terms of the libraries?
SETH LADD: The question
was about testing.
Just last week, I think it
was, we put the unit test
library into the SDK.
There's a couple
[? on ?] this.
There are like three floating
around there.
And we're kind of like, yeah,
let's pick one, put it in.
And I know of another third
party testing environment too,
which is really cool.
It's so exciting to see
some choice there.
It's still early days.
In the core library, there is an
expects class with a set of
functions, pretty
low-level stuff.
But then you still need to wrap
that, like [? a U test ?]
framer.
That's the one we
just shipped.
But it's really early
for that too.
It takes cues from the
Jasmine and RSpec.
So if you're familiar
with those, this
should look fairly familiar.
But what we haven't shipped--
we stopped there.
It would be interesting to see
what else we or community
could do around browser
level testing.
So we have this buildbot guy,
that's running all these tests
on all the browsers, checking
out performance and
conformance.
We may see like, can we expose
that more or encourage
community [? building ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's turns out that there's this
tool from the Chromium
project called dump render tree,
which is basically a
headless Chrome.
Which is really awesome
for testing, actually.
So, actually, nearly no
one knows about it.
And it would be cool if other
people keyed in on it.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you guys, what's better than
running your app in the
browser it's pointing to.
And the real live thing, and
not emulated at all.
But it's some
[? script for me. ?].
AUDIENCE: Well, some of the
tools that I use in my LAN
layer, I use a headless
webcam.
Either for JavaScript speed
tests or for functional tests.
SETH LADD: So you guys are going
in the right direction.
AUDIENCE: What's this?
SETH LADD: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a
little bit about the
philosophy of Erlang,
in terms of, I know
there's like futures?
Like [? how ?]
[? kind of ?] errors get
bubbled up through?
SETH LADD: Sure.
So that's specific to
just the futures.
I guess I can go
to the library.
I'm sorry.
Are you familiar with like
offsets or defers or
something like that?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So I have something
to talk to here.
Actually, this might not
give you what you want.
Well.
So for those of you who don't
know, futures are what-- it's
a way for you to return a token
for something that will
happen in the future.
And allowing your immediate
client code to say, OK, when
you get a response,
do this thing.
To me, it sanitizes the
call back heavy code.
And I like futures a lot more.
Especially when you have
a chain method.
You can turn what would have
been just like deeply nested
or deeply spaghettified call
back in those into what
appears to be layer code.
But then, at the end, you can
have a halo exception method.
So in the specific case of
futures, if an exception is
throw inside one of
the actually--
it's under the logic, your
future, you can subscribe it
down into here.
Does that answer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SETH LADD: So the exceptions
will bottle up, just like the
actual results, which in the
future, the result bubbles up.
And for instance that there.
[? Our ?] futures are cool.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
It's kind of a broad one,
so preface it with that.
It seems like Dart would have
been better off not having to
be compiled down to JavaScript,
like if you had a
genuinely clean slate.
I understand why you would
want to though, from an
adoption stand point.
SETH LADD: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm not sure
what my question is.
It seems like the goal would
be, if this is successful,
really, for every browser to be
able to be opened directly
without that.
I'm hearing it's not fun.
SETH LADD: I don't know how much
we'll cut into the video,
so I'll just repeat it.
You're point it,
same click it.
AUDIENCE: How held back do think
Dart is by the fact that
it, initially, has to compile
down to JavaScript?
SETH LADD: How held back do we
think Dart is due to the fact
that it has to compile
to JavaScript?
I don't know.
But I think that option is
totally off the table.
Chrome loves the web.
We love the web that do this.
We're all web engineers and want
to see the web succeed.
And we have to be
very pragmatic.
It has to compile to
modern JavaScipt.
Now we do draw a line.
We do draw a line that says,
legacy browsers with older
implementations of JavaScript
are really slow performance
and aren't interesting to us.
We're online for IE,
IE9, right now.
But again, it does include
Chrome for Android, Mobile
Safari, Safari 5.1, Firefox.
Basically, M minus one for us.
Chrome N minus one
is out right now.
Yeah, to get any adoption-- to
help web developers developing
apps, we want to see
LAN on the web.
It Has to be deploy to
the Brahman browser.
And so it's just a core
tenet of Dart.
Its things a fact a life.
And I think that the team's done
some amazing things like
with isolates, optional types,
the broad support for
libraries here.
And you still get in all this
composite JavaScript.
I mean, that's pretty
impressive.
So I think the developer will
still see a tremendous amount
of productivity gains, once
this gets fleshed out and
launches in like this
1.0 release.
We're ready for anything.
AUDIENCE: Copy script
is doing OK?
SETH LADD: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's do one more
question, and then we'll
wrap up [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
What is the status of work for
like more advanced browser
API, like GL?
SETH LADD: So the
question was--
AUDIENCE: [? String or audio? ?]
[? Web Workers? ?]
SETH LADD: What's the safe
support for broad navigational
applied family APIs?
So we're pretty good.
And if it's not there,
it's a button.
So you can just scroll through
this thing, you'll see, here's
the next [? EV ?].
Down here, is Web GL.
Here's Web SQL.
Here's SVG.
So it's our intent to expose all
the regulational [? buy ?]
of APIs and features
with Dart, through
the Dart HTML library.
Absolutely.
I mean, here's your
typed arrays.
AUDIENCE: Are you set
on port 3js to--
SETH LADD: We're not, but
luckily somebody already did.
I should have put that
on my slide.
That's another good one.
Yeah, there's a 3 dot Dart.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Seth.
SETH LADD: Thank you.
I'll hang around for as long
as you guys have questions.